et on commence ce journal avec une
disparition inquiétante à nantes depuis
le début du mois d'avril on est sans
nouvelles d'un couple et de ses quatre
enfants
et ce matin des restes de corps humains
ont été découverts au domicile de cette
famille d'après le procureur l'en quête
se dirigerait vers un assassinat audrey
richier d'abord qualifiée d' inquiétante
la disparition depuis le 4 avril d'une
famille de six personnes à nantes a pris
une autre ampleur ce matin je
m'apprêtais à lancer un simple appel à
témoin qui bien sûr est maintenu mais ce
matin même il ya quelques minutes un
reste humain a été découvert dans le
jardin de cette famille sous la terrasse
et l'enquète bascule donc
malheureusement nettement sur une
qualification criminelle
jusque là la famille semblait s'être
volatilisé les téléphones coupés plus
aucun mouvement sur les comptes
bancaires
aucune trace ni dans les aéroports ni
dans les gares et sur la boîte aux
lettres une invitation à renvoyer le
courrier inquiet des voisins ont donné
l'alerté
des amis de ces enfants là sont venus
aussi chercher les informations donc
avait pas été du tout prévu comme ça ça
nous a un petit peu inquiété les
voitures sont restées sur le trottoir
enfin tout ça fait qu'il ya eu quelques
petits signes qui nous auront fait
penser que ce n'était pas une départ
tout à fait naturel le départ paraissait
pourtant organisé une lettre a été
envoyée à l'école des enfants évoquant
une mutation en australie mais à
d'autres
le père de famille a donné une tout
autre explication assez grand nombre de
proches de cette famille ont reçu un
courrier dans lequel monsieur au nom de
la famille expliquait qu'il était en
quelque sorte un agent secret pour le
compte des états unis et qu'il devait
retourner dans le cadre d'un programme
de protection des témoins aux états unis
pour assister un procès important lié à
la drogue
seule une des trois voitures de la
famille est encore garées devant la
propriété
ce matin les policiers ont installé une
immense
bâches pour protéger ce qui n'est plus
une maison vide mais une scène de crime
épilogue macabre donc pour ce qui était
jusque là une disparition mystérieuse
trois corps et même un quatrième juste à
l'instant été découvert au domicile d'un
couple et de ses quatre enfants des gens
qualifiés de sans histoire mais qui
n'avait pas donné signe de vie depuis le
4 avril dernier à nantes romual bonnan
gabriel camilla c'est dans le jardin de
cette maison nantaise dissimulé
désormais derrière une énorme bâche
noire que les enquêteurs ont trouvé les
corps de trois personnes tuées
vraisemblablement par arme à feu
ce 2 3 des membres de la famille de
ligonnès tous enveloppés dans des draps
et enterrées dans la propriété depuis
début avril
xavier lepercq agnès la mère ainsi que
les quatre enfants âgés de 14 à 21 ans
n'avait plus donné signe de vie
dans un premier temps la justice avait
lancé un avis de disparition inquiétante
aujourd'hui la sphère prend un nouveau
cours roquettes bascule donc
malheureusement nettement sur une
qualification criminelle de
séquestration et d'assassinât selon les
premiers éléments de l'enquète un départ
précipité de la famille avait été
programmé une lettre avait été envoyée
aux écoles pour des scolarisés les
enfants avec un motif une mutation en
australie depuis les téléphones
portables était resté muet plus aucun
mouvement sur les cartes bancaires seuls
quelques proches voisins avaient
remarqué les allées et venues troublante
du père ce qui m'intrigue et c'était son
le ballet l'acquitterez n'arrêtait pas
de traverser et de remplir
coffre de sacs de gros cabas voilà donc
et en bermuda pour nos chaussures bateau
effectivement c'est ça veut dire mon
compagnon gym qu'est-ce qui fait le
voisin pour ceux qui fréquentaient la
famille le drame demeure inexplicable
l'acheminent été très gentils les
parents étaient gentils saharienne avec
avec tout le monde et c'est pour ça que
je comprends pas ça un peu un mystère
pour moi
désormais la police recherche un
véhicule 4 4 appartenant à la famille et
un appel à témoins a été lancé on
continue au delà du traumatisme à ne
rien comprendre à cette affaire on parle
d'un père toujours affable d'une famille
discrète sans histoire jusqu'à sa
mystérieuse disparition au début du mois
les amis et les proches ont profité de
ce vendredi saint pour les catholiques
pour organiser un moment de
recueillement anne-charlotte in et
eloïse mallet l'office du vendredi saint
était prévu de longue date mais
aujourd'hui les paroissiens de saint
félix ont tous prier pour la famille de
ligonnès qu'il connaissait bien
à la sortie d'église des visages fermés
pas de commentaire mais certains
confient leur incompréhension
bien sûr qu'on est tous sous le choc on
a du mal un petit peu à comprendre cette
date
agnès la mère de famille était une
catholique très pratiquant discrète
aussi elle était surveillante dans cet
établissement scolaire donner aussi des
cours de catéchisme impossible pour ses
employeurs de soupçonner la moindre
faille au nièce était une personne qui
était à l'écouté des enfants qui étaient
heureuses des tables blanches et qui
manifestait une adéquation avec le
projet de l'école et tout ce qui s'y
déroule est c'est donc une surprise pour
nous entière le profil du père xavier de
ligonnès est en revanche plus floue un
homme souvent absent du domicile
familial qui semblait avoir des rentrées
d'argent mais aussi beaucoup de dettes
impayées depuis 2003 il occupait ce
local commercial à pornic une société de
publicité sur internet dont on sait peu
de chose si ce n'est qu'il ne s'y
rendaient visiblement plus depuis un
certain temps elle n'a pas fait son
changement en fait d'agra
c'est pour ça que vous receviez du
courrier à son nom pour envoyer tous les
quatre enfants de la famille avaient
tous suivi leur scolarité dans cet
établissement privé
ce matin les amis d'anne 16 ans qu'ont
voulu lui rendre hommage et mettre des
mots sur un drame qu'ils ne comprennent
toujours pas j'y croyais pas je pensais
que c'était un film où comme dans une
série et non voilà et on pleure et c'est
toujours douloureux surtout les
circonstances quoi ce matin une cellule
psychologique a été mise en place pour
aider ces élèves à surmonter cette
épreuve
les éléments que nous avons pu
recueillir ces derniers jours permettent
désormais de mieux cerner la
personnalité et le parcours du père de
famille un homme de 50 ans aux multiples
visages enquête
audrey richier matthieu nivesse globe ce
qui avec nos bureaux à poitiers et
montpellier il est l'homme le plus
recherché de france mais quel est le
vrai visage de xavier dupont de ligonnès
l'homme a plusieurs facettes
le berceau de la famille ce château en
lozère dont les années 70 le comte
hubert dupont de ligonnès son père
abandonne femme et enfants la famille
s'installe à versailles un bon vivant
farceur généreux c'est le souvenir quand
on a gardé un camarade de lycée
son voisin sur les bancs de l'école
l'écrivain bruno de stabenrath pour moi
y est c'est un gentleman qui aimait la
vie qui était un bon vivant qui aimait
les gens qui met profondément les gens
dans la rue y parle avec tout le monde
qui était très ouvert d'esprit qui était
cavell corps le coeur ouvert qui était
généreux trop sec trop rigide trop
cassant ainsi le décrit sa femme en 2004
sous pseudonyme
elle livre son mal-être sur internet un
mari absent tantôt en été tantôt
flambeur lui veut donner l'image d'un
travailleur acharné mais ses anciens
partenaires gardent des impressions très
différentes
je suis très intelligent très
calculateur en gros un mur
donc moi depuis je connais depuis 2003
elle n'a jamais payé un centime de
théâtre que honnêtement il
leur entrée 10 à 15000 euros par mois 2
pour moi c'était un bon père de famille
quelqu'un quelqu'un en qui y avait
encore une fois tout confiance et qui ne
paraissait sympathique et agréable
on ne pourra plus jamais nous joindre
voici comment termine les lettres que
xavier dupont de ligonnès a envoyé
depuis sa maison de nantes à tout son
entourage début avril
méthodique le père de famille semble
avoir organisé la mort des siens
plusieurs semaines à l'avance depuis
décembre dernier il s'entraînait
régulièrement dans ce club de tir il y à
un mois
il pousse la porte de ce marchand
d'armes à nantes ils cherchent des
munitions qu'il n'obtiendra pas il est
passé à peu près 10 nuls chez nous se
renseignant comment faire pour acquérir
une arme de poing
sa famille était en danger donc il
souhaitait s'équiper de quelque chose de
ce type
et puis voilà mais par contre il s'est
présenté comme étant prêtre tireur
d'élite heures la religion la fois
depuis longtemps il la met en avant au
point de choquer sur ce forum catholique
et d'en être exclu un homme énigmatique
beaucoup le décrivent ainsi ce serveur
est le dernier à l'avoir vu avec un
membre de sa famille xavier dupont de
ligonnès dînette avec un de ses trois
fils dans ce restaurant à angers
c'était le soir du 4 avril ils avaient
peut-être déjà tué le reste de sa
famille
la discussion était fermé le jeune était
assez replié sur lui même
on sentait bien qu'il y avait un souci
quelque part le papa nous avait affirmé
que son fils était malade
mais bon on sentait bien avec ma
collègue kong qui avait quelque chose
autre sa trace se perd le 15 avril
devant cet hôtel dans le var où il a été
vu seul et où il a abandonné sa voiture
on en vient à cet élément de plus dans
l'énigme de la disparition de xavier de
ligonnès soupçonnait vous le savez du
meurtre de sa femme et de ses quatre
enfants
pour la première fois on entend la voix
du suspect dont on est sans nouvelles et
pas dans n'importe quelle circonstance
le soir même des meurtres il laissé un
message téléphonique à sa soeur sur un
ton très naturel très décontracté
anne-charlotte inné et yann one un
message de 35 secondes
apparemment banale xavier dupont de
ligonnès l'a laissé sur le répondeur de
sa soeur le 3 avril à 22h37
alors que d'après les enquêteurs il
s'apprêtait à tuer sa femme et au moins
trois de ses quatre enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons fait écouter la bande à ce
psychiatre expert auprès des tribunaux
il ya des mots un peu cryptée ya en
particulier il dit qu'il va coucher des
enfants
ce qui est bizarre à leur âge c'est un
homme qui maîtrise parfaitement ses
affects qui est capable d'un double
visage qui est capable d'improvisation
c'est christine la soeur de xavier
dupont de ligonnès qui a remis ce
message aux enquêteurs elle voulait
ainsi démontrer son innocence
quand elle a eu le message le lendemain
matin c'est un message parfaitement
normal qu'elle a parlé avec son frère à
midi pendant une demi-heure de tout et
de rien et que plusieurs jours après
semaine je dirais on lui annonce que ce
jour là cette nuit là son frère ou son
fils aurait
décidé de tuer toute sa famille elle ne
peut pas croire à sa culpabilité
depuis le 15 avril aucune trace du père
de famille mais la traque continue de
nouvelles recherches devraient bientôt
être organisée aux alentours de
roquebrune-sur-argens là où xavier
dupont de ligonnès a été vu pour la
dernière fois
[Musique]